PRAMODA: I'm Pramoda.
GILLIAN: I'm Gillian.
PRAMODA: Gillian.
And our game is--
You know how on the iPhone you
have those games like Jetpack
Joyride or something.
It's like one of
those games that
has a player moving
infinitely, and you
have to click to make it
jump or go left or right.
It's kind of based off of that.
That was our inspiration,
except it's in 3-D. Well,
I guess you should just play it.
GILLIAN: We'll demo it.
PRAMODA: She'll just demo it.
GILLIAN: There's music.
We don't know how loud
it's going to be just
from my computer but--
PRAMODA: Hopefully it'll play.
AUDIENCE: Make sure you
maximize [INAUDIBLE]..
PRAMODA: So the cube is moving
infinitely in the plain.
You can collect coins, and
that'll make your score go up.
If you touch a cactus,
those are like enemies.
That'll destroy your lives.
You start off with five lives.
What she just picked
up is a capsule.
So you see the little
bar at the bottom,
that's how much fuel you have.
You can only fly with
just hitting space bar.
Fly for-- OK.
GILLIAN: You can go underwater.
PRAMODA: Yeah, you can
also go underwater.
So there's coins
under the water.
So you go under there, and
you can collect secret coins.
And then you fly by
pressing space bar,
but if you see the bar down
there, if you run out of fuel
you can't fly in
the field anymore.
And so you just keep going.
I think we touched a few
cactuses along the way.
GILLIAN: Did we?
You can lose a life.
PRAMODA: You lose a life
by touching the enemies.
GILLIAN: I'll get
another capsule.
PRAMODA: Now she can fly.
We have three worlds.
So this is the desert
world, and then she
is going into the snow
world which also has coins.
GILLIAN: It's pretty simple.
PRAMODA: Then obviously
the coins spin around.
This world isn't as long
as the desert world.
You can see the forest
world showing up already.
There's also coins in
the air, but you can only
get them if you have fuel.
You have to know
exactly where they are.
There you go.
I think our high score is 20,
so if anyone can beat that--
GILLIAN: I'm about to
run out of fuel, as you
can see on the bottom left.
And you have this thing at
the top where you click it
and it mutes the music.
These are conifer trees.
PRAMODA: So you
can run into them.
GILLIAN: You can hit them.
The grass is actually
compiled, so you
can see how you're kind
of submerged in the grass.
PRAMODA: So it's like
going through a meadow.
And it's funny because
the grass is actually
a bunch of little trees.
You can't see it now, but
if you zoom in infinitely
you'll see the tiny
little trees swaying.
It's really funny.
GILLIAN: You basically get
to the end of the world.
PRAMODA: And then that
is the end of the game.
And then I think you
will fall infinitely.
GILLIAN: You will [INAUDIBLE].
PRAMODA: You just fall
infinitely into space.
That's our game.
GILLIAN: So we can talk about
some challenges that we had.
Basically we split up the
work into two separate groups.
I mostly worked on
building the world,
because I found the terraforming
tool of Unity fascinating.
I spent hours doing that.
It's so cool.
So a lot of the more
complicated things--
you can see the
canyons and the cactus
and the trees-- were
imported from Unity Assets.
All of them were
free, although there
are some that are up to $40.
And basically the ground,
the terrain I hand-created,
but the canyons and cacti
were created and imported.
But I did hand-place all of
them, and I hand-designed it.
The river-- Let's
see if I can zoom in.
The river was interesting
to create because--
It's not that hard.
Unity makes it
relatively easy for you,
but to get it to have--
To apply the
physics to the river
properly is kind of complicated.
You can't really tell because
of the way we have it,
but there's actually water
everywhere in this world.
And if you dig deep enough,
you will get a pool.
So I can show you that.
AUDIENCE: It's like
real life, or something.
You just keep digging
and there's water.
GILLIAN: So, let's see.
Inspect-- this is how
you do the terrain.
Here, can you hold that?
You can actually do
this, and then you
can see water coming up.
You can make it go
up like that, but I
don't want to make it ugly.
So I had a lot of
fun doing that.
And then she worked
on the coding parts,
as far as the game track.
PRAMODA: I did mostly the code.
There's not really that
many different codes.
I don't know if you can--
Where are the scripts?
Right.
So there's really only a few
simple codes over there, but--
So the coins, they have
their own little code
so that they spin
around, which--
That's the code for the player.
Just the player.
So the weirdest part
was to get the cube
to always move infinitely.
So originally you could move
it forward and backwards,
but we just had to
figure out how to make it
so it never moves backwards.
That's not an option.
So that was just
something different
that I had to figure
out how to do.
And then this is just a
bunch of different codes.
Actually, the
hardest part I think
was doing the health
bar, to make it go down.
So obviously you can
make integers go down,
but to make that visually
happen was really weird.
But you just have to use a local
scale or something like that.
So that was pretty simple
after I figured it out,
I guess, but in the
process it was hard.
GILLIAN: Overall, the game
was really fun to make.
We actually worked on it a lot,
on our own time after class.
She was here until 11 last night
at my dorm room working on it.
PRAMODA: Because we were like--
GILLIAN: It was maybe 30%
done until last night.
PRAMODA: And it really
came together last night.
And we were like, what
could we add more?
I think we just kept on going,
and at a certain point in time
we were like, we
should stop now.
This is enough.
That's about it.
GILLIAN: That was our game.
AUDIENCE: What
were the controls?
GILLIAN: Just arrows.
The left and right arrow,
and then space bar.
PRAMODA: Yeah,
that's all you have.
Space bar to jump, until
you run out of fuel,
at which point it locks
the space bar so you can't.
GILLIAN: You can't go up
anymore, until you get a--
AUDIENCE: Do repeated space
bars make you go higher?
PRAMODA: Yeah, you continue to--
GILLIAN: It's like a force every
time you hit the space bar,
so you can go pretty high.
PRAMODA: So you continue to fly.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
AUDIENCE: Any other questions?
[APPLAUSE]
GILLIAN: Yay.